The end is finally near for NASA’s Kepler
spacecraft, with the fuel tanks expected to
run dry in August of 2018.
But before the undisputed champ of exoplanet
hide-and-seek retires and drifts off quietly
into space, we thought we’d look back on
the highlights of the nine year mission.
Kepler was launched in March of 2009 with
one mission: to search for planets outside
our solar system.
Rather than orbiting the Earth like the Hubble
Space telescope, Kepler was placed in what’s
called an earth-trailing orbit around the
sun, a little wider and a little slower than
ours, So, over time it would slowly drift
away from Earth until it was millions of miles
out.
That means we can’t send astronauts to repair
Kepler like we’ve done with Hubble, but
so long as nothing goes wrong this orbit has
a lot of advantages.
It keeps the Earth from photobombing the shot,
and since it’s out of Earth’s atmosphere,
the stars won’t twinkle.
The orbit also eliminates external torques
caused by atmospheric friction or Earth’s
magnetic field, meaning the craft can stably
point at one spot in the sky for a long time.
The largest external torque on Kepler comes
from solar pressure, but four small wheels
that act as gyroscopes stabilize the craft
and counteract that.
Aside from a disposable cover, these are the
only moving parts on the spacecraft, reducing
the chances that something will break.
Once in orbit, Kepler continuously stared
at the same patch of sky in the Cygnus-Lyra
region, watching 150,000 main sequence stars
for the tiniest drop in light levels that
indicate a transiting planet.
The only time it broke its gaze was once a
month when it turned to transmit data back
to Earth.
It was basically the most formidable staring
contest opponent humanity could create, and
it caught stars blinking.
Kepler identified over 2,300 confirmed extrasolar
planets, 30 of which are less than twice earth’s
size and in the habitable zone, making them
candidates to support extraterrestrial life.
Kepler chugged along just fine for a while,
even though one of it’s reaction wheels
broke in July of 2012.Then in 2013, four years
after launch, disaster struck.
Remember all that foreshadowing I did, about
the wheels being the only moving parts and
the craft being too far away to repair?
Well a second wheel broke, and two functional
wheels was not enough to keep the camera steady.
Without the ability to stabilize itself Kepler
couldn’t continue the original mission,
and it looked like the end.
Until, someone had a brainwave: why not use
the solar pressure to act like a third stabilizing
wheel?
Kepler wouldn’t be able to look where it
had before, but it could point at one spot
for about 80 days at a time, until sunlight
would start leaking in.
At which point it could rotate and stare at
a different spot for another 80-ish day “campaign”.
The crazy plan worked, and the new mission,
dubbed K2, was underway.
The K2 mission has discovered another 323
confirmed exoplanets, and there’s still
lots of data to dig through so more could
be confirmed years from now.
K2 has even had some unexpected benefits.
By looking at a variety of stars, many of
them in early stages of their lives, Kepler’s
observations have lead to discoveries and
insights into how stars and young planets
form.
After 5 years of the K2 mission, Kepler is
running out of fuel, meaning soon it will
not be able to point itself back towards Earth
to transmit scientific data.
While NASA originally estimated it would only
have enough fuel for 10 campaigns, the little
spacecraft that could completed 18!
It makes me want to light a menorah or something.
Its successor, the Transiting Exoplanet Survey
Satellite, or TESS, was launched in April
of 2018, and will search almost the entire
night sky for exoplanets.
But if exciting news ever comes out about
a planet with Kepler in its name, you’ll
know the story of the amazing spacecraft that
discovered it.
If you like this video don’t forget to subscribe!
Kepler isn’t the only space telescope whose
time is running out, soon the legendary Hubble
space telescope will be put out of commission
too.
For a fond farewell to this stargazer, check
out Athena’s video here.
One cool thing thing about the Kepler mission
is it was operated by undergrad students as
young as 20.
It’s the next best thing to being a self-made
billionaire.
Thanks for watching and I’ll see you next
time on Seeker.